you
[Music]
mad flavor here Cleveland Ohio the man
behind the dumpster
sparking the bone of death God knows
where the [ __ ] I am well I know it's
freezing understand me
Friday January 13th you gotta love your
cat today these [ __ ] are killing
black cats thinking they're gonna talk
to [ __ ] Satan there's only one way to
top the Satan I got the answer you had
killed 20 black catch and I get nowhere
I'm smoking the ball of death some
[ __ ] that I brought with me this is
called the carry fish old G this will
kill everybody and their mother you know
saying is how good this is
recite that it's a beautiful day to be
alive here it's a little cold but who
gives a [ __ ] you got a swing they can
get bubblegum and any climate they put
you in you understand me that's what it
means to be a [ __ ] seal
I'm not a seal I can barely do push-ups
but who gives a [ __ ] you know I'm saying
uncle Joey and full effect it's Friday
the first week of the II had passed and
you made it see them talking about who's
better than [ __ ] you
come join pipe bomb I'll still blow
smokes again it'll not beautiful anyway
look sitting that's that I got two shows
tonight
my gosh do shows demonic
I'm gonna do some right today maybe some
lifting I couldn't go to jujitsu I'll
have to go tomorrow my main man diamond
over there you meet her but besides that
that's it it's on and on we don't stop
[ __ ] 24/7 when you sleeping
[ __ ] lights up later
[ __ ] like I said creep it you
understand me why because we're animals
that's why we're [ __ ] animals you
could take my note you can take
everything he put me on a [ __ ] island
and I'll still get out of that did I
tell you this weed is [ __ ] tremendous
coast to coast I get to the hotel the
package is there
[ __ ] wait for you I'm saying you
don't sir what do you got talk to people
you got a mango you gotta be sociable
you don't think
and that's it and that's that I just
wanted to check them what you haven't
forget about you you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart what I
you I have who got so [ __ ] I got a
check we use from time to time make sure
you're still doing your thing make sure
you're not slipping you know these
[ __ ] to three days of doing
good things and they slip they go back
to eating that bad ass you gotta be on
the tip-top form every [ __ ] day you
gotta make a checklist make a checklist
that's why you write your goals
[ __ ]
speak BAE is coming to the show tonight
late show out of respect
because he's a good [ __ ] savage it
couldn't be the heavyweight champion a
world without respect you can't get no
one in this life without [ __ ] respect
respect the others respect little
animals respect the people with white
hair you gotta respect
and that's it looking around it looks
like Cleveland which looks like Jersey
which means I'm at home blue collar big
balls and no [ __ ] gluten-free [ __ ]
[ __ ] walking around oh my god that
burrito
I love Portlandia go [ __ ] yourself go
[ __ ] yourself
get a life stop lying to yourself stop
trying to live for these other people to
be cool I wanted Hillary then nobody
fight get it together
all right we're good to the [ __ ] knob
we're going deep today
turn it up you know why cuz we ain't got
time to [ __ ] around
we gotta be tip-top Magoo
7:24 and I said that's that